(laughs)
- [Man] Wowww!
Okay!
- I bet you didn't think
that was comin' today!
♫ We're unstoppable
- Super excited this morning,
got super fired up.
Been listening to 21 Savage & Metro Boomin
all morning.
They just dropped an album.
That's always good,
when Savage is
get excited here.
What else?
Two groups of people,
very much top of mind for me right now,
18 to 25 year olds
and 40 to 50 year olds.
Same shit.
Lacking patience, in very different ways.
18 to 25,
just early, young, cliche impatience.
But the 40 to 50 year olds
who don't realize that
(rap music playing)
who don't realize that they have
(music stops)
their whole life
in front of them.
And I know that sounds ridiculous
to some, especially if you're under 30,
like, what?
50's so old!
It just isn't.
You got 25, 30, 35
hardcore productive big-time
years in front of you.
And to be very frank,
I'm trying to suffocate both
the under 30 set,
and the 40 to 50 year old set.
I don't have anything right now
for you 30 to 40 year olds.
(laughs)
But, you know
the under 30 set and the
40 to 50 year old set,
is super fascinating to me
just huge trends in my DM's,
in my emails.
I just can't wrap my head around people's
lack of perspective.
And that is what I'm gonna focus on.
Framing up the perspective,
the reality of the situation.
Last night's talk at Samsung
I think really had a ton of fire.
I hope Iris edits it right,
I hope we get a bunch of microclips for
Instagram for it,
Facebook, because it's just,
it's just a very
interesting time in my life
as I become more in tune
with the opportunities
and the realities of the game.
It exposes the ones that aren't,
and I feel a level of guilt
of almost responsibility
to over-communicate
given my communication style
to you, to just somehow
tweak your brain and make you see it
and so,
I'm on fuckin' mission.
There he is.
- Not bad!
- Not too bad.
- Considering
- Great to see you.
No worries.
Matt Higgins, the brains of the operation.
- What's up?
Let's get this on.
♫ Southside
- Now when people come out
with signature sneakers
(fast-forwarding noise)
When Durant comes out with something
- Yeah exactly,
we dropped the KD 10.
- And there's only one?
- Three, but then,
each couple months it's like
(fast-forwarding noise)
- Maybe we'll just call it The Vee.
- Yeah.
- V-e-e.
(hip hop music)
(phone texting)
Where's Iris?
She has a lot of stuff from yesterday.
The keynote at Samsung was
fuckin' loaded.
Loaded!
(phone texting)
Hey man, real pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- How are things?
- Good, good.
How are you doing?
- 'Sup man?
How are you?
- Pleasure, pleasure.
- Real pleasure,
sit, sit, sit.
What's cookin'?
- Nice to meet you finally.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you, man.
So what's going on?
What can I help you with in this
short period of time we got?
Here's the best part,
and you've heard this from me.
Go home,
this might be the best thing that
comes out of this meeting.
Go home and be like,
how do I get traffic
from Pinterest on Google
and just fuckin',
give me 10 hours
- Yeah.
- If you're still playing in that field,
you love that field,
you give me 10 hours of watching videos,
reading free content,
and then start hacking,
you're one Pin away from insanity.
And while everybody's
looking at influencers
and Facebook,
and that demo against that product.
(camera photo)
Love it.
Take care of yourself.
- Thank you.
- Good luck.
Try that, let me know how that goes.
- I am.
- I don't know if you're
in the mindset for it,
but before you go away we can do
a little voiceover of a story?
- Marissa Bird and Robbie
Turnick got together
at 9:01 am,
and were waiting for Gary V
to pop out,
he would always be a
little bit late because his
Russian mother would always make sure
he ate a little bit of breakfast
like they did in the old country.
While Marissa and Robbie
were super excited about either
playing basketball or hopscotch, or spud,
Gary had a different agenda in mind.
Today, they were going
to wash people's cars.
Gary was feverishly running door to door,
ringing doorbells,
negotiating, haggling, and trying to get
somebody to pay five
dollars to wash their car.
Finally somebody answered.
Gary gives his best pitch,
which is met with an
unsuccessful conversion,
and the door closes.
While Marissa and Robbie are shook,
Gary loves the fact that
he lost his first at-bat.
And is only motivated dramatically more
to go to the next home.
After 11 more minutes
and seven more doorbells
and two more rejections,
finally on the cul-de-sac down the road,
somebody bites
and the team gets to action.
Gary rings the doorbell
to show the great work they've done,
which is met with a great smile and a
glass of lemonade.
And the team moves on.
It's 11:07, and they're
onto their next mission.
I'm so talented, it's scary.
(laughs)
- [Man] It was good?
- It was probably better than good,
it probably reminds me
that I might be all-time.
The fact it's the first
time I tried to storyboard
an animation
and I did it improv in one take,
and it was that remarkable.
Yeah I mean it's difficult,
it's difficult for me to
comprehend my talent.
That's a nice sweatshirt.
100 percent!
- [Woman] This is my
Halloween costume.
- You are very perfect.
- I nailed it!
- You nailed it.
(laughs)
Guys, best Halloween costume ever.
Look, it's me.
- It's mini-you.
Well, actually we're like the same height
so it's fine.
- Be careful.
I fuckin',
I don't know if this is
the same fuckin' height.
I think we've got some
confusions around here.
(laughs)
- Thank you so
- You're welcome.
It's awesome!
If Tyler's saying it's bonkers,
in a world where we live bonkers
(laughs)
I'm like, what is it?
So I'm like, rolling and I'm
looking at my schedule and I'm like,
am I flying to Australia,
giving four speeches
on two hours of sleep,
and then flying back 30 hours later?
Vlog, the answer is yes.
- [Man] You have no idea
how grateful I am to you.
I mean just for what you do
day in and day out.
I think the difference that you're making
in people's lives
is staggering!
- Listen, man,
I don't even want to begin to tell you
if I can live long enough,
I can have a real profound impact.
- Yeah.
- And I can feel it
running through my entire soul.
And I'm completely, like
weirded out by it
in an incredibly exciting way.
- Sure.
- I mean this is
absolutely potentially my great legacy.
- Yeah.
- And I actually am
struggling to figure out
how it's not gonna be.
- Right.
- Because if you could really get
27 million,
17 million, 49 million
'cause I think globally on this issue.
- True.
- Men, 15 to 25
to fundamentally rewire themselves
and become more noble and kind
and compassionate,
and empathetic and grateful
and positive.
- Thank you so much, man.
- Such a pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure, my friend.
Hey everybody this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 270 of the
#AskGaryVee Show.
Hey Alexa!
Buy my soap!
- [Alexa] Did you want me to find soap?
- Yes!
- Got it.
- I mean this is,
hey Alexa, buy this!
I mean, that's it.
I just bought Dove men's soap.
- Order placed.
By the way, I can now
send you notifications
about future shipping updates.
- Hey Alexa,
buy an iPhone charger!
- Okay.
- Just buying shit here on the
#AskGaryVee Show today.
(laughs)
You know, and even watching you guys
and even watching Seth right now,
imagine brushing your
teeth in the morning,
remembering that you need socks,
and saying in your bathroom,
hey Google, hey Apple,
hey Alexa, hey Facebook
or whatever else comes out,
I need,
and now the question becomes,
why was that Dove?
And who has the power?
You think end caps at retail
at Walmart are powerful?
Fuckin' Amazon.
Why do they choose that?
How much do you pay
to be the first result?
You think Google AdWords are expensive?
I don't think people understand
what the fuck is actually coming.
Making anything happen, D-Rock?
I mean you've been,
you've been sitting here so I feel like
you should be making something happen.
- [Man] Yes.
- Hi, Gary.
- Hi.
How are you, hi.
What happened in the 50's,
60's, 70's, 80's, 90's,
even in the early 2000's
was the golden era of
television, print and radio.
That was a world where
the consumer was there
and the pictures and
videos and written words
that fit that medium were perfect.
And it was great!
It was a lot of fun.
Let's not forget, prior to television,
the radio dominated.
And the people that knew
how to write jingles
and make sounds that
had great written words.
Because we've lived in the TV print era
of the last 50 years, 60 years,
people didn't want to give it up
when the internet came along in '95,
'cause that was a long run of 50 years!
That's the way it was.
Starting in 1995 with Windows '95,
the internet became consumerized.
Normal people started
getting on the internet.
And now we're 20 years into that.
There's full maturity.
There's people that are now at scale,
we buy things on the internet.
The internet controls our attention,
now it's with us at all times.
And so, the consumer moved.
The advertising industry
doesn't get to choose.
It has to move to where
the eyeballs and ears
and attention of the consumer is.
There's a lot of,
there's five major holding companies
that make billions of dollars
that don't want it to change.
Why do we love
Zeus or Spider-Man?
Right?
Why do we love these things?
We love as human beings
origin stories.
These luxury brands, literally,
have the best origin stories.
Yet, because of the
limitation of television,
outdoor billboards, and print,
they've never been able to tell them!
This is a documentary,
every fashion brand in the world
should make four documentaries
of how it happened.
That is propaganda.
That is media.
That is marketing.
And the fact that you can post that
in a Facebook environment and have
millions of people see it.
You don't need to make
a deal with the BBC.
Netflix doesn't have to pick it up.
This is incredible flexibility,
this is the greatest
time for luxury brands.
But yet,
they hold on, they hold on because
they put themselves on a pedestal
and they've looked down
at the modern communication tools.
Much to their detriment.
Hey Alexa, buy this!
- [Alexa] Order placed.
By the way, I can now--
- I just bought
a 30 dollar pair of boots.
Just right now.
So, how
- [Alexa] I don't understand.
- Alexa, stop.
How I think people need to realize
how to be the boot that comes up on Alexa
when people ask for a coat or a boot
or an umbrella or a sneaker--
- [Alexa] Sorry, I'm not sure
- Alexa, stop.
I think this is incredibly powerful.
I don't think people understand.
People are just now trying
to figure out influencer
or Facebook and Instagram,
and the world's already moved
to the next frontier of voice.
Listen,
if the fashion brands,
the high luxury brands
think it's complicated now,
and it feels tight now,
wait 'til they see the next 10 years.
The biggest, most historic
brands of our time
are going to go out of business.
(phone texting)
- [Man] Good time for
a little update, too?
- I've been working.
(phone texting)
(dramatic hip hop music)
Tell me I'm wrong on this issue.
Just like, Calv.
Can somebody make me feel good about
me being wrong here?
It's fuckin
an hour and a half in,
there's 17 of us,
and I don't have a BSU.
- Came out at one, the episode.
And then--
- Great.
That's even worse, keep going.
- And the next morning,
the video now
- I just, I can't wrap my
this is,
you guys know me.
I'm not in the one strike policy.
I'm not in the three strike policy.
Like, we have 17 fuckin'
people on our team!
You just texted last, don't worry.
I'm not,
I don't even know!
I don't even know,
I just take it as one collective,
we suck shit.
There's 17 of us.
I care about like four things
that I bring up.
We just need to figure it out, please.
That sucked.
(phone texting)
Guys, I'm always right if
I complain about something
'cause I never complain
about anything ever!
It's binary.
- Right, but
- The end.
There's not buts and more importantly,
what's way more ridiculous
is I can deal with anything.
But the audacity not to communicate
that we're gonna deliver on it,
is ludicrous!
You can fuckin' post it at 3:40
if you can make me understand why.
But, there's no way out of this
with a but,
because there wasn't even the
respect or kindness
to even acknowledge
that it wasn't gonna happen.
And more importantly, why?
Why are we behind?
I got it.
Then I wanna hear from
you at 2:30 in the morning
that I expect us to be an hour late.
Because then I'll say, no.
And I'll say, Baban wake up,
help him.
Like, I don't get it.
If we're gonna have,
at a macro
I don't care about you tripped
and the fuckin' hard drive
went into the garbage
at a macro.
If we're gonna make a
commitment to a time,
then let's deliver on the time.
We're not doing it right!
And we have no excuses.
So like,
we just don't.
So like, we need to start
asking each other for help.
Doing something, because
it's not working for me.
It's not working for me.
So,
when it doesn't work for me,
that's a problem.
(floaty pop music)
Vlog,
you need to follow this man.
- Hey, what's going on?
- It'd be a really
good decision, vlog.
- Follow this guy.
- I'm sure some cool Instagram pop up
just came up here and post at it.
(laughs)
I'm sure it's phenomenal.
You won't regret it.
- Thank you man.
Appreciate you.
- What's that?
(floaty pop music)
(phone texting)
We doin' all hands on?
- [Man] Yup.
- Let's go.
(dramatic music)
(audience applauding)
Hello hello hello.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, VaynerMedia.
Happy Halloween.
Today's all hands on is
to announce a little fun
thing that I'd like to do
which is that
nine individuals at VaynerMedia
will be going to Helsinki, Finland.
Yup.
(audience laughs)
We do some random shit
around here sometimes!
(audience applauding)
Have a great day, see ya.
(laughs)
Maybe I'll nominate you.
Good to see you.
Good to see ya!
Hey!
What's up, man?
How are you?
- Good.
- You think you're
getting any nominations?
Are you gonna jockey for it?
You think you'll get any nominations?
- Maybe!
- Have you been kind
to your fellow homies?
- You wanna ask?
- Helsinki, anybody?
Travis let's talk about
something way more important.
Helsinki.
- All you have to do is
send an email about me.
- He's gonna try to get
people drunk with some whiskey
and then say, hey!
Send the Helsinki fuckin' email!
Hey bro, you like bourbon?
(laughs)
I like Helskini.
How you guys doing?
- Good!
Excited!
- I think you'll get zero nominations.
- I agree!
- How are you, man?
- Good.
- Good to see ya.
Helsinki?
- Yeah.
- Helsinki!
(uplifting piano music)
- Jay Shetty.
- Hi, Jay.
How are you, man?
- Good to see you, man,
finally.
- Great things about you,
brother.
- It's fine.
- Thank you, my man.
How are things?
Sit sit sit.
- Thank you, man.
- Jay interviewed me at
NASDAQ a little while ago
and we started following each other
and I just kind of became
obsessed with his content,
just in general.
I think I mentioned this
to you.
- You did, I dug in,
I saw the pretty eyes.
(laughs)
I filled in the whole thing.
- Relationships I think is huge.
- I agree.
From a guy's perspective.
- Yeah, exactly.
- He had, I saw one of them.
One of the two videos that went
completely viral on Facebook
on relationships was like,
it's very relatable.
It's not just for guys,
girls are gonna love this stuff
that he's talking about too.
- It's cool to meet you man,
where do you live, here?
- I'm based out of New York,
but I travel so much for work.
London
- And what are you doing now?
- So, I'm basically
just social video.
- Yeah.
- Social video, branded sponsored content,
workshops,
- Yep.
Understood.
Yep.
Real pleasure to meet you.
Good luck to you.
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah I hope we get
to see each other soon.
- Me too.
- For sure.
(phone texting)
No worries.
Dinner, or
self promotional but
I think the merit of
the creative ultimately
plays itself out, right?
Do I think I'm gonna win a
hell of a lot of business
super long-term, because
I'm gonna be proven to
be historically correct?
Absolutely.
Just the truths, right?
I don't really focus on
anything other than my truths.
I've been blown away by how,
it's worked better than I thought.
So my intuition is, yeah.
It is.
(phone texting)
(dramatic music)
Pleasure.
- Same here.
- How are you my man?
- Doing good, doing good.
- Real pleasure.
Hey.
- What's up, sir?
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
How you doing?
- Great, man, great.
- Sit, get comfortable.
How's life?
- Great.
I know you always on the move, on the go.
- Yep.
- So, bruh, what's sleep?
Like how often?
- My man, sleep is important.
I'm not worried about how
many hours people sleep,
I'm worried about what they're
doing when they're awake.
- Mmm!
- I'm trying to get
six, seven, eight hours.
Like the body is
- Mmm!
- Not jokin' around.
Like, I got a little bit,
I was just complainin', I'm
goin' to Australia next week
for two days and I'm
only sleeping two hours.
I don't know what my
assistant was thinking.
(laughs)
People are just wasting their at-bat.
- Man!
Heyy, I like that!
You on deck, you wait, you
try to get your opportunity,
then you too tired to hit the goddamn
- A hundred percent.
And then you prefer to sit
and dwell and complain.
- Mmm.
- And people just come
up with a million reasons
why not to do.
I just get so many kids who wanna be you.
- Yeah.
- And a lot of them
don't have much, and I'm like
Work at Chick-Fil-A, save
your money, go in a studio!
- Exactly.
- I mean like, I don't know,
what do you want me to tell you?
- Yeah.
- And then what's even
crazier, actually, is
the shit you can now do that doesn't even
need studio time.
Right?
It's not what you and
I grew up with, right?
I mean the technology's
you know what this is?
- I know what,
a studio!
(laughs)
- This is a studio!
That's exactly what it is!
(group laughs)
It's just suffocating out excuses.
- Oh my god!
(laughs)
- You know, right?
Is there anything that
since we got time together,
is there anything that
stands out that I can
answer, I can help with,
is there anything we can do?
- Yeah, and I run into a theme where,
and he'll tell you where he's like, bruh,
you need to tweet something,
you need to IG,
- And it's not your
natural state.
- It's hard for me
How do I
- Let me tell you,
as somebody who goes
the complete other way,
- Yeah.
- And peacocks, you know?
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- It's probably the way you
feel about your music, man.
I feel so good about what I'm saying
- Yeah.
- That I'm willing to take the heat.
- Okay.
- You know how many
people don't put out music
'cause they don't want to take the heat?
- Mmm.
- Most of them.
- So you need to not
talk when he wants you to
'cause it's smart strategy.
You need to find a way to,
when you feel something,
to talk.
- Okay.
- Right?
If you can convert it,
in the way you think about music,
the reason I put out so much shit is
I got something to say!
Listen, if you did a
fuckin' Instagram story
right now and said,
I'm taking an intern
to be my videographer,
I'm not gonna pay you shit,
and you get to follow me
around and make videos
and put it out,
fuckin' 10,000 people raising their hand!
(laughs)
You know how many people
would rip their arm off
that love you more than life to do that?
Two years ago when I decided
to film everything I did,
I'm like,
that's some douchey-ass shit, right?
(laughs)
Like how am I going to
explain that, you know?
But I just knew it was right.
Like in the world that I live in my dome,
imagine all those videos
we could be watching
of when Pac and Biggie were friends?
- Oh my God!
- You know how fun this is?
My man, you and I are
gonna sit there and break
and eat some food in 13 years
and pull up our phone or whatever,
and watch this!
- Yeah.
- And by the way, let
me go on a real crazy
left turn on you.
- Okay.
- You're just gonna like having this
when you're an old man,
because your kids are
gonna be able to watch it.
- Yeah.
That's real.
- In the world that I live in,
my kids, my great-great-grandkids
long after I'm gone,
are gonna sell this meeting,
sell it as virtual
reality and they're gonna
be actually sitting right there.
- Man.
- 'Cause they think you're cool,
'cause they think I'm cool,
'cause I'm their great-grandpappy
and they're gonna sell it!
- Mmm.
- Yeah it's crazy!
(laughs)
But I promise you
the guy that drew Batman
never thought in 70 years
there's gonna be billion
dollar movies made.
You can't project that far out.
- Right.
- But I can!
(laughs)
A little bit, a little bit.
A little bit.
There's something else
I've been thinkin' about,
I want to throw you since
the vibes I'm feelin'.
This is something, you haven't
heard this one yet from me.
- No, let's go!
(laughs)
Bring it on!
- I have a concept that I haven't seen.
- Okay.
- Song comes out, album
comes out, project comes out.
Something pops!
In movies, they come out
with number two, quick.
You put out, right,
Guardians of the Galaxy.
You're like, what the fuck happened?
It blows up in the theater,
they're fuckin' in
production on number two,
from the bat!
You write a song.
It's about what you're goin' through
with your girl.
With your best friend.
With somebody sick in your family.
And it goes.
Well it's been some time
in between you writing that
and now it happening.
- Mmm.
- To write the update,
and piggy back off the momentum is
something I've never seen.
- So quick question.
- Yes sir.
- Would that not be considered a remix?
- No, because remixes
are other people's ideas
on top of it.
- Well it could be your ideas.
- The remix is
some form of a collaboration
that's building off
the equity of the popularity.
There used to not be
anything called the remix.
- Right.
- I'm old.
(laughs)
When I grew up,
there was no remix.
There isn't something
called the follow up,
or the update.
But I think it can happen.
The speed in which you can do things,
that's,
that fuckin' excites
because I'm in it, you have to understand
who I am as a listener.
I'm in it for the story.
- Mmm.
- Right.
- You're not just talking
about going to the club
and having fun which is great
- Yeah yeah.
- When you're
telling life's stories, life didn't stop!
And if that song went,
and you've got a couple more
lines to add to the equation,
that is super interesting.
A project that took two years to come out.
A song that resonates.
A truth that there is a follow-up story,
not fabricated.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That you can get generated about.
And then it comes out 11 days later,
and everybody's been feelin' that song
and now you're telling what happened?
You're feeding 'em.
- Yup.
(laughs)
Woww, okay!
- I bet you didn't think
that was coming today!
My man.
- Thank you, tonight.
- Yeah.
I'm gonna see you guys tonight.
I'll see you guys tonight.
Take care.
Vlog, great way to end.
Incredible talent, Big Krit.
Going to Halloween now.
Doin' that Halloween thing!
We'll see you later.
(hip hop music)